اجتماع طارق لنتولي بحثي ازمه الصاروخ
الذي سقط على بولندا وبيض نيو يرشحوا الا
يكون اطلق من روسيا
وبولاندا تؤكد تعملها بهدوء مع ازمه
الصاروخ وتطلب تفعيل الماده الرابعه من
ميثاق النيترو
جني كمان
[تصفيق]
رئاسه
السابق خذل امريكا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى فتره اخباريه جديده
من العربيه
عقد رئيس الامريكي جبيل عن طريق مع عدد من
قبضه الدول العشرين لبحث قضيه سقوط صاروخ
قيل انه روسيه على منطقه شرق بولندا قرب
الحدود مع اوكرانيا
حول تقارير ارتباط انفجار بروسيا قال بيضا
ان هناك معلومات اوليه تعارض ذلك وانه لا
يريد ان يجزم في الامر لحين التحقق من
الامر بالكامل مضيفا انه من غير المرجح ان
الصاروخ اطلق من روسيا نظرا لمسائره
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطونيو بلانكين
بحث من جانبه وخلال اتصال هاتفي بنظيره
البولندي زيبي جونيور وزير الخارجيه
اوكرانيا يتم يتركوليبا تداعيه سقوط صاروخ
بشرق بولندا وتعاهد بلنك لنظريه البولندي
والاوكراني مواصله التنسيق فيما بينهما
بانتظار نتائج التحقيقات بحادثه بولندا
لتحديد الخطوات اللاحقه
هذا هو قال رئيس البولندي اند جيده انه
ليس لديه ادله دامغه حول مصدر الصواريخ
التي سقطت على اراضي بولندا وانه لا يوجد
اي مؤشرات على احتمال تكرار ما حدث رئيس
البولنديه اشار الى انه يتم التعامل مع
قضيه سقوط الصواريخ بشكل هدف مؤكدا ان
بلاده ستطلب تفعيل الماده الرابعه من
ميثاق النيدو خلال اجتماع الحلف اليوم
اما رئيس الوزراء البولنديه فقال انه تم
اتخاذ قرار بزياده الاستعداد القتالي
لوحدات مختاره من القوات المسلحه
البولنديه مع التركيز بشكل خاص على المجال
الجوي لبلاده مضيفا ان ذلك يتم بتعون مع
الحلفاء
لمجموعات عسكريه من الجيش البولندي مع
التركيز بشكل خاص على مراقبه المجال الجوي
وهذه المراقبه للمجال الجوي ستتم بالتعاون
مع حلفائنا
المقابل نفط روسيا امبارح استهداف قوتها
لاهداف في بولندا وقالت الدفاع الروسيه ان
الحديث عن سقوط صواريخ روسيه في بولندا
استفزاز متعمد يهدف لتصعيد النزاع واشاره
الدفاع الروسيه الى ان الحصان الذي
اظهارته صور لا يشير الى استخدام اسلحه
روسيه وقال نائب في مجلس الدوله
الاوكرانيه متورطه في الانفجار فقط بولندا
من ذاته قال المتحدث باسم الكريم لندن على
رويترز انا لا معلومات لدى الكريملين بشان
الحادث الذي وقع في بولندا
وفي ردود الفعل ايضا اعلن المتحدث باسم
الحكومه البولنديه بترومولر ان الوضع
متازم بعد سقوط صاروخ الوصي على اراضي
بولندا وداع الاجتماعي عاجل لمجلس الامن
الوطني وعبر الاتحاد الاوروبي في بيان عن
صدمته بشان التقارير التي افادت بسقوط
قتلى في بولندا جرا سقوط الصاروخ وقال
النتوه انه يجري تنسيقا مع الحليب بولندا
بشان التقارير عن سقوط صاروخ على اراضيها
كما اعلنت الخارجيه الالمانيه انها تراقب
عن كتب الوضع في بولندا وتلصق مع الحلفاء
بعد الحادث هولندا اشارت بدورها الى ضروره
معرفه ما حصل في بولندا بشكل دقيقه كما
اعلنت رئاسه ليتوانيا عن تضامنها القويه
مع بولندا فيما قالت حكومه تشيك انه اذا
ثبت سقوط صواريخ روسيه على بولندا فان ذلك
سيعني تصيدا من قبل روسيا المجر اع بدورها
عن اجتماع لمجلس الامن القومي لبحث ما جرى
في بولندا واكدت خارجيه استونيا انها
جاهزه للدفاع عن كل شبر من اراضيه النساء
اكد ترياسه الوكرانيه ان اكثر من سبع
ملايين من منزل اوكراني محروم من الكهرباء
بعد ضربات الروسيه الجديده استهدفت شبكه
الكهرباء في البلاد فيما اعلن الرئيس
الاوكرانيالسكي بعد استهدافه بلاده بوابل
من الصواريخ الروسيه ان موسكو لن تحقق
هدفها بتدمير البنا تحتيه لطاقه الاخرانيه
اكثر من 100 صاروخ اطلقتها روسيا على
العاصمه الاوكرانيه
الرئيسيه للطاقه وفق ما اعلن سلاح الجو
الاوكراني
امتدت اثار القصف الى خط مهم للكهرباء يمد
بالطاقه الدوله المجاوره مولدوفا والتي
اعلنت عن انقطاعات هائله للكهرباء في
انحاء البلاد بعد قصف روسيا لنظام الطاقه
الاوكراني في الساعه الماضيه انقطع احد
خطوط الطاقه الذي يؤمن انتقال الكهربائي
الى بلادنا وعدد ذلك الى انقطاعات هائله
الكهرباء في انحاء البلاد
دوي الانفجارات كان قد سمع في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف غربا وفي مدينه خار كيف
شمال الشرق البلاد وعقبه ضربات الجويه
انقطعت الكهرباء في العديد من المناطق وفق
مقاله السلطات الاوكرانيه
كما تسبب اوابل الصواريخ الروسيه على
مناطق اوكرانيا باندلاع الحرائق في عده
مباني سكنيه وبتدمير البنيه التحتيه
للطاقه الاخرانيه وفق اعلان الرئيس
الاوكراني فولودي ميرسي
يطلقوا 85 ضربه صاروخيه على اوكرانيا وعلى
مدننا في الغالب على البنيه التحتيه
للطاقه من الواضح هذا ما يريده العدو ولن
يحققه هدفهما ربما هناك ضربات في المستقبل
لذلك اطلب من الجميع توخي الحذر والبقاء
في الملاجيء لفتره من الوقت اعلم ان
الضربات قطعت امدادات الكهرباء عن العديد
من المدن في بلدنا نحن نعمل وسوف نستعد كل
شيء وسوف ننجو من كل شيء
وداع عمده خارقين السكان للبقاء في
الملاجئ فيما اعلنت شبكه النت بلوكس عن
اضطراب كبيرا في خدمه الانترنت في
اوكرانيا بعد الهجمات يشار الى ان الضربات
الصاروخيه الروسيه اتت فيما يستمر القتال
شرقا بين القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه كما
اتت بعد ايام على الانسحاب من غير سنجنوبا
وفي خضم عقاد قمه مجموعه العشرين في
اندونيسيا
جديده لرئيس الروسيه تامر رئيس الروسيه
الدول الغربيه باعاده صياغه تاريخ العالم
في محاوله لاضعاف روسيا وتقود سيادتها
وذلك خلال اجتماع الافتراضي مكلف باحياء
ذكرى الحرب العالميه الثانيه في روسيا
شيخ باسماء
العالم واعاده تشكيله اكثر عدوانيه ولديها
بشكل عام هدف واضح على الاقل في ما يتعلق
بمجتمعنا وهو التفريق وحرماننا من مبادئ
التوجيهيه وفي النهايه اضعاف روسيا
والتاثير على سيادتها لتقويده
يرشقون قوات الامن الايرانيه بالمفرقعات
باصفهان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اهلا رئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب ترشحه للانتخابات
الرئاسيه لعام
وقال من منتجع مارادو في فلوريدا انه
سيخود السباق البيت الابيض للمره الثالثه
واشارت وكالات الانباء باينه
بالفعل يوم الجمعه امام هيئه الانتخابات
الفيدراليه الامريكيه
نحن هنا اليوم لنعلنا انه ليس بالضروره ان
يبقى الوضع على ما هو عليه قبل عامين كنا
امه عظيمه وقريبا سنكون امه عظيمه من جديد
عام 2014 هو الموعد لتصويت افضل هل انتم
مستعدون وانا ايضا مستعد ساضمن على محصول
بيض على اربعه اعوام اخرى بلادنا لا
يمكنها ان تتحمل ذلك انني اعلن اليوم
ترشيح نفسي لمنصب رئيس الولايات المتحده
في الجوله المقبله
ورد رئيس الامريكي جوبيدين على اعلان
مره اخرى للانتخابات الرئاسيه بالقول ان
ترامب خذل بلاده خلال توليه منصبه وقلبه
في تغريده من بالي ان ترامب وخلال
الرئاسته تربع على اقتصاد مزور لصالح
الاثرياء وهجم النظام الصحي ودلل
المتطرفين وهاجم حقوق المراه وحرض
العصابات العنيفه من اجل محاوله قلب فوزي
بيض عام 2020 الى خساره
هذا هو تسربات معلومات منذ اسابيع على ان
وزاره العدل الامريكيه تسعى لتوجيه تهم
لرئيس السابق ترامب في قضيه الوثائق
السريه التي بحوزته لكنها تؤجل ذلك الى ما
بعد نتائج انتخابات التشديد النصفي
النهائيه
حاضر قضيه الوثائق السريه في مقر الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب في مراغو على اهتمامه
وزاره العدل الامريكيه منذ اشهر وتسربت
معلومات بدايه الشهر تشير الى ان المحققين
ربما يوجهون توهما للرئيس السابق في هذه
القضيه
الرئيس
كان قراره وليس بالخطا او بدون علمه ربما
لا يكون وجود الاوراق السريه وفيها
معلومات عن البرامج النوويه لدول اجنبيه
في مقر الرئيس السابق سببا كافيا لتوجيه
تهمه اليه من قبل وزاره العدل انما اعدم
تعاونه المشكله
سيكون توجيه التهم المحتمله تحدي كبير
للرئيس السابق لكنها ليست نهايه المطاف في
حين يتعرض لاكثر من ملاحقه قانونيه
الاتهامات لو حصل هجوم من الدوله العميقه
لمنع الرئيس من العوده الى البيت الابيض
فسيكون لهم موقف مختلف
[تصفيق]
الرئيس الرئيس
على ان الطبقه السياسيه تعتبره تحديدا
وستفعل اي شيء لمنعه من العوده الى البيت
الابيض
الاندفاع السياسي ايا كانت الظروف
القانونيه في الرئيس ترامب يحظى بتايدا
حار من قبل قاعدته والهدف هو والعوده الى
البيت الابيض
ايه الاحتجاجتي ايران فقط خرجت تظاهرات في
عدد من المدن ورشق المتظاهرون قوه الامن
بالمفرقعات في اسبانيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
واكما تشاهدون حضراتكم هذا فيديو متداول
لقوات الامن الايرانيه وهي ترتدي ملابس
مدنيه وتحاول اعتقال عدد من المحتاجين في
مناطق في شمالي طيران
هذا هو كشف المسؤول في الاستخبارات
الايرانيه عن تفاجئ النظام بالاحتجاجات
التي عمت البلاد مشيرا الى انهم لم يكونوا
يعلموا بوجودي مجموعات تحقد على النظام
بهذه الصوره
كتابه كتابه
[موسيقى]
ومن صله ومن سلسله تقارير هذه النشره تعيش
تونس على واقع جرائم عنف وقتل ضد النساء
ذهب ضحيطها اوضحيتها عدد كبير منهن في
مختلف جهات البلاد جرائم قتل النساء هزت
الراي العام التونسي واطلقت معها منظمه
حقوقيه حمله تحت شعار اوقفوا قتل النساء
للتمديد بسلسله الجرائم التي استهدفت عددا
من التونسيات في الفتره الاخيره
في هذا الحي الفقير بمنطقه وادي الليل
بمحافظه منوبه جريمه جديده تحدث وتهز
الراي العام حيث اقدم رجل على قتل زوجته
تعلن وحاول قتل ابنته الكبرى تموت الام
مخلفه اربعه اطفال قصر ويكون مصير الوارد
السجن
عينيها اثنتين وتعنها في مناطق حساسه من
جسمها حكاياتها واطفالها الاربعه القصر
كما ترويها لنا
رجلها عينها خلف
وجهي فما عوم فيها زياده يعني في وجهي في
جسمه زياده في مناطق حساسه هناك امراه
يعني متصالحه مع نفسي
تصالحت مع نفسي
وطالبه مسكن ولادي
شهيده تونس الى حدود شهر اكتوبر المنقذي
15 جريمه قتل ضد النساء
والفحالات العنف المادي والمعنويه ما هذا
الراي العامه في البلاد
تحت شعار النساء
هما اللي ماتوا واللي يمثلوا فما اسمه
هديت بالقتل في اي لحظه في اي لحظه اي
ضحيه عنفه نجمه ولي للاسف مرحومه ورغم ان
القانونه يفرض على الدوله تامين الحمايه
للمعنفات علاوه على توفير الرعايه الصحيه
والنفسيه في مواجهه ظاهره العنف لان
تقريرا رسميا كشفا ان الاطار الاسريه بات
فضاءا حاضنا للعنف وتحولت البيئه الاسريه
الى بيئه غير امنه فعداد قتل النساء
والاعتداء عليهن في تونس وتنوعت الا انها
تبقى جرائم صادمه في مجتمع ان يؤكد
المختصون تراجع منسوبي القيم الانسانيه
فيه مؤخرا في انتظار حلولا من دوله تباهي
بريادتها في مجال حقوق المراه وليد عبد
الله العربيه
تونس
اسره يمنيه الى اتخاذ احد المنازل المدمره
غربيه تعز مسكن لها بعد ان نجحت من جحيم
الميليشيا الحوتيه ويبيت افراد تلك الاسره
يوميا داخل بقايا بنايه دمرتها الميليشيا
الحوثيه بقضاء فيها في حي المطار القديم
ما يجعل حياتهم معرضه للخطر
مدمره اضطرت اسره الى اتخذه مسكنا لها بعد
انفرت من جحيم
فالسكن فيه مؤقت رغم انه اكثر خطرا على
حياتهم من ذاك الخطر الذي تهددهم لاعوا
منه في المنازل قبل النزول
الى هنا للمطار القديم
واضطرينا ان احنا نسكن داخل هذه البيتفون
مدمر انا واسرتي وعائلتي
وانو اعاني من السؤال ما يشاء ومن القصف
ومن الحرب هذه
وكل يوم قذف مع الحرب هذا ضرب هون الا
الحاره والمواطنين وترعيه بالاطفال
والمواطنين
فهذه الاسره التي فقدت معي لها بقديفه
حوتيه تشكل يوما الوحده وقسوه المعيشه في
ظل الحرب
ظروفنا الخاصه تمام يعني ما عندناش
امكانيه ان احنا
والمستقبلين ما هو من الله بس الان يعني
اناشيد المنظمات واصحاب الخير بالايتام
الان ما فيش حد مني الفتهم ولا احد ولا هم
ولا من يجيب لهم ولا اي حاجه
اكثر من 3000
يعيشون الوضع نفسه مع التردد الوضع
المعيشي خاصه اولئك الذين يعيشون في
المخيمات فالغالبيه منهم لا يحصلون على
احتياجاتهم الاساسيه من الغذاء والملابس
الشتويه التي تقيهم اقل ما يمكن من البرد
سعيد العربي العربيه تعز
ونذهبوا انسانيه الى بريطانيا مع تزايد
تكاليف المعيشه وما تتسبب به من تراجع في
قيمه معاشات التقاعد ومع ارتفاع اسعار
الخدمات والانشطه الترفيهيه يتزايد شعور
المتقاعدين بالوحده وتتراجع صحتهم النفسيه
والبدنيه المزيد في تقرير الزميل مصطفى
زارو من لندن
كبار السن في بريطانيا بشان تاثير ازمه
ارتفاع كلفه المعيشه
حديثا تواجه ضغطا كبيرا لتغطيه الزيادات
الضخمه في الاسعار
عبر مراجعه قوائم الضروريه والاستغناء عن
الكثير من الكمال
ذلك في الاشهر القليله الماضيه تغيرت
حياتي كثيرا تخلصت من سيارتي ومصارفها من
بنزين وتكاليف المواقف والصيانه واجرت
غرفه ل 5 سنوات لانني بحاجه الى دخل
اضافيه لراتب تقاعدي ميشال تحاول التامين
اكبر قدر ممكن للمستلزمات معيشتها
الاساسيه في ظل صعود اسعار الكهرباء
والغاز وغيرها من السلع كما ان نسبه
التضخم الاعلام منذ اربعه الى جانب ارتفاع
كلفه الاقتراض كلها عوامل اثرت على قوه
الشرائيه مع التراجع قيمه معاشها التقاعدي
الى جانبي مبيعات اعمالنا الفنيه
ومنحوثاتها عام السامريزت لابسه
احب المسرح والسينما لكن لا يمكنني تحمل
تكلفه تذكره مسرح الان وارخصها احيانا 35
جنيها وهذا كثير بالنسبه لي اشاهد نتفليكس
وغيرها من البرامج بدلا من الذهاب لتناول
الطعام مع الاصدقاء انهم مجرد جنون اما
مشتريات الشهريه فهي المزيد من الخضار
والعدس واصبحت اكثر ابداعا في الطهي
لمواجهه غلاء المعيشه
تزيد اعمارهم عن 60 عاما ويعانون من
الشعور بالوحده ودخل محدود غير كاف لشراء
المستلزمات الضروريه بحسب استطلاعه الحديث
ما اهم الى التخلي عن ضروريه الى جانب
انشطه ترفيهيه واجتماعيه تخرجهم من العزله
والوحده وتحسن حالتهم الصحيه والذهنيه
والنفسيه مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن
اعلنت فرنسا عن ترحيليها 44 مهاجرا تم
انقاذهم عن طريق السفن في ايطاليا وقال
وزير الداخليه الفرنسيه
رفضت 44 طلب لجوء قدمت من اصل 234 مهاجرا
تم انقاذهم في ميناء طولون العسكريه
بالبحر الابيض المتوسط مشيرا في الوقت
ذاته لان كافه المهاجرين الذين تم رفض
طلباتهم سيعودون الى بلدانهم الاصليه
ختاما وكالمعتاد مع ابرز العناوين
اجتماع طارق
ازمه الصاروخ الذي سقط على بولندا وبيضن
يرجح الا يكون اطلق من روسيا
وبولندا تؤكد تعملها بهدوء مع ازمه
الصاروخ وتطلب تفعيل الماده الرابعه من
ميثاق نيته
ترامب يترشح رسميا للانتخابات الرئاسه
2024 وبيضن يرد بان الرئيس السابق خذل
امريكا
نتواصل بعد قليل في نشره الاخباريه جديده
من العربيه ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]